that's a great pleasure to be back with
you I did not bring any PowerPoint
slides I had a chance to be here in the
fall and talk a little bit about what
I'm thinking about right now but I have
to begin by saying when I heard the term
last lecture series I had a kind of
senior moment and thought it referred to
my last lecture and then I started
worrying about the selection criteria in
the market you know people on their last
legs and so on so my I think Myron had a
similar and then I realized it was your
last lecture series and I felt better I
want to tell you one story it's
completely sort of an aside I guess but
I had a great good fortune just luck to
receive the Nobel Prize in the year that
was the hundredth anniversary of the
Nobel Prizes not actually economics
which began and I think 1968 but all the
rest of them and so I think there were
700 to 750 Nobel Prize winners in the
first century one of whom was Myron and
and of those that maybe 280 or so were
still a lot so they invited them all
back now there's only two requirements
once you've been selected to receive a
Nobel Prize you actually have to show up
in Stockholm and you have to give a
lecture and they're serious about this
and normally when you give this lecture
you give it to a distinguished group of
Swedish faculty and students in your
field plus other interested people well
but in this one year something happened
that probably couldn't happen any other
time in your life when I said got up to
give this lecture in the front row with
Myron Scholes Bob Merton Paul Samuelson
Milton Friedman Perry Becker and I
literally started to shake okay
I this taught I was told that this was
rather open-ended so the way I got
started thinking about this lecture was
I I thought about my own life which is
now accumulated 60 years and I made a
lot of mistakes in the course of this
life and I thought I learned from some
of those mistakes and so I mentally
started assembling the subset of that
learning that I thought might be useful
or a value to you and then I thought
started to think well now I've got a
time limit here so I ought to figure out
a way to wedge this all in to the time
and I was getting kind of frustrated by
the whole exercise so I asked my wife
Monica what I might I ought to do and
she said well you could just speak very
slowly let me be briefly
autobiographical I grew up in Canada
actually we both did
miron was a student and I played ice
hockey and when I was 11 I played for a
team called Ted spells Ted actually
existed he is the worst hockey player I
ever saw just without question but his
parents owned the largest drugstore
chain in Toronto and they co-sponsored
the team along with the Chicago
Blackhawks and I played defense with Ted
and experienced this egregious departure
from meritocracy and
and I learned a lesson which is not
everything is a meritocracy and I found
I learned something about myself which
is that and and about other people later
in life which is some people react very
badly to that I found I reacted to it
with kind of amusement but it is
certainly a feature of the world
we played 96 games that year and won the
national championship in Canada and my
grades as the pundits say sky rocketed
downward and the athletic director of
the school I was in it is a man named
jack life I remember him very well
because he was four foot six and he now
remember I'm 11 so he called me into the
office and he looked up at me
this is true and he said if you do that
again meaning play for that team I'll
get you kicked out of the school so I
looked we were too polite in those days
to have an argument with an elder but I
look pretty skeptical and he looked at
me and he said young man I want you to
understand just one thing he said this
is a democracy and I run it so that was
my first lesson in governance in an
academic setting I moved on I actually
did become a better student and a worse
defenseman and have headed off to
college at Princeton where I think I was
told later that I was the only known
admissions mistake they thought I could
play hockey
we were actually it was a great fun
playing there we were terrible
well maybe not just that we weren't very
good and but there wasn't much to do in
Princeton on the weekends in those days
it wasn't co-ed and we were the best we
were the best comedy show in town for
those of you who like baseball and
history we were the New York Mets of
college hockey
we made hilarious mistakes and snatch
defeat from the jaws of victory mostly
because we had a goalie who was a cross
between a sieve and a funnel depending
on whether
the puck was going so I eventually
decided to try to become a teacher and
scholar and had a wonderful time doing
that and then for reasons I've never
fully understood I ended up for a period
of time in academic administration as a
Dean and one of the first lessons I
learned in that job and the first one
was at Harvard was that students had no
idea what a Dean does none so I was the
Dean of Students the Dean of freshmen
the Dean of the college whatever I was
really the Dean of the Arts and Sciences
and when I my wife and I got married I
told her what I had done at Harvard and
then I overheard her introducing me as
the Dean of Arts and Crafts
presumably that well-known Harvard
summer camping but slightly slightly
more seriously one of the things I think
not everybody does belong some do and I
certainly have his kind of change
careers I mean in a significant way
changed what I was doing for chunks of
time so I was a teacher in scholar
mainly for about 15 almost 20 years and
then a Dean for another 15 and now I'm
kind of indescribable II spread out but
I want I thought I'd just say a couple
of words about about that pattern of
career and I thought I'd do it in terms
of benefits and cost so the benefits are
pretty easy to describe for those who
have an inclination to do this kind of
thing there's change
there's challenge there's a lot of
learning which is both fun and and
actually quite useful if there's any
relationship between these things the
costs are a little harder to describe
and I thought a lot about this I think I
can put it this way what you think to
yourself when you're doing this is
expanding your portfolio learning new
things becoming a broader person and all
that that's not what you may be the only
person who thinks that other people
remember vaguely for a while what you
did before I remember I went through
being the former economist to the X
economist to the late economist but what
really happens is that eventually you
get to a point where nobody remembers
what you did before and some of the
enjoyment of a career is all the stages
of it and you will you will give up some
of those later stages by this switching
around I didn't realize this at the time
I was kind of consumed by the the fun
the learning the challenge and to be
honest I wouldn't change any of it now
but I thought I would tell you that
there are real costs associated with
this hopping around I don't think this
is an occasion when one should hand out
advice and I will try to avoid it the
place where advice gets hands that
handed out in large quantities
courses that graduations which many of
you are going to experience in the near
future but I do want to tell you a story
Monica and I listen to the Prairie Home
Companion a lot and Garrison Keillor
came on one day and said he was
describing a graduation address that he
gave at a high school in Minnesota
several years ago and in the course of
this address
you know he was handing out free advice
he urged the graduates not to be afraid
to make mistakes
ie not not to be too risk-averse in the
choice of careers and activities what
they do which is actually pretty good
advice I mean I've even given that
advice because I think for people who
were as talented as you are there are a
lot of things including not only not
wanting to disappoint yourself but all
the people around you who have very high
expectations of you who kind of push you
in the direction of not taking a chance
on not being as successful as you have
but be that as it may anyway he told
these young people and not to be afraid
to make mistakes and a few years passed
and he learned quite by accident that a
non-trivial fraction of that class ended
up in jail for a variety of kinds of
white-collar crimes at which point he
said he thought to himself and said on
the radio you know I didn't mean big
mistakes
I meant little mistakes like using the
wrong fork your salad that kind of stuff
well I still think the idea of not being
afraid to fail in the pursuit of
improbable goals is something which is
worth bearing in mind and I'll come back
to it a little a little bit I'd like to
say a word about the world in which you
are going to be important leaders and I
think honesty compels me to say and I
say this with some sadness because I
think when I think of it I think of you
and the things that you will face as
challenges but also my own children
it's it's a world that's pretty complex
myron and i grew up in a world which was
dominated by the cold war
pretty well for our whole adult life and
while the Cold War wasn't fun in the end
the idea of mutually assured destruction
certainly wasn't pleasant the Cold War
had a stabilizing effect in the
aftermath of the Cold War it seems to me
is a much more difficult and messy world
it on the one hand is a world of
increasing connectedness economically
and in terms of lawless technology were
fascinated with communication ability to
integrate markets create new markets
integrate supply chains change values of
of assets intangible and tangible all
over the world but it's also a world as
fragmenting in a particularly dangerous
way as I see it and part of the reason
for that is that there are increasingly
apparent dramatic differences in income
wealth health education and hope that
are threatening to tear this world apart
I don't think anybody seriously argues
that terrorism is caused by purely
economic phenomena deprivation on the
other hand most people would agree that
a you know that where you have a world
in which there are terrorist
organizations surrounded by literally
hundreds of millions of people who do
not reasonably believe that their
grandchildren and their children will
have a chance to live with less
deprivation than they have that that
world is a is a fertile field for
disaffection and violence and even
terrorism I view this as at a kind of
summary level the great challenge that
your generation is going to have to face
head-on
it's an incredibly hard set of problems
it's part economic part political part
governance part communication and it
will probably take the best the human
mind and spirit has to offer for more
than one generation to make a big dent
in this and I wouldn't presume tonight
to suggest how this should all come out
but it seems to me there are
opportunities to make a dig difference
there are leverage points there are ways
to think about it that are promising
even though the challenges are great so
I don't think of it as hopeless but the
part the one part of this complex
equation that seems to me is certain is
that if the citizens of the advanced
countries we are approximately 20% of
the world's population but if we don't
think of this and by this I mean health
education and economic progress for the
other 4 billion people who don't live in
advanced country if we don't think of
this as a priority and it isn't clear to
me that we do then nothing will happen
and the reason is that we live in
democracies and we are used to the idea
in our economic and personal lives that
we all pick things to do and it works
pretty well
I mean economies work and decentralize
in a remarkably effective way and it
goes beyond that we pick our local
communities and we live in different
communities and we support them but it
doesn't get at the notion that we have a
collective a collective responsibility
in my view to get some of these
priorities that run all over the world
right so we live in democracies and
therefore it's either us or nobody who
are going to set this there's a priority
if we don't think it's a priority it
won't be a priority to take a running
shot at these tremendously challenging
things and to me what that means is that
over time we have to imagine that the
idea of citizenship will change somewhat
not dramatically my way I think of it in
quantitative terms is that the idea of
citizenship becomes a little more
expensive expansive it's an extension of
it to the notion that it goes past our
own borders
in America and in the GSP we have a big
advantage where as a country a
collection of immigrants we're two
perfect examples of that we have ties
family and other all over the world we
are diverse we have learned how to live
together in a diverse way and much of
the same could be said as the mirror
image in this wonderful school that
you've been in and come and in addition
we in America are uniquely in the
position of having an enormous amount of
military and economic power so it seems
to me that putting those two things
together we have a kind of natural
leadership role that's been thrust upon
us for a period of time it won't last
forever and I think it's important now
let me be specific there are 30 to 40
million hiv-positive people in the world
AIDS is in the process of partially
destroying at least one continent six
million of those people are active AIDS
cases there are countries in which more
than 30% of the elementary school
teachers are hiv-positive and will
likely develop active AIDS symptoms on
the other hand in the last few years
that science that we've come to rely on
is developed remarkably effective and a
retroviral drugs so we have an
opportunity here that probably we're
talking 50 to 75 billion dollars but
more important and then here's the
challenge it's going to take a it's
going to take setting up priorities and
it's going to take a coordinated assault
by Nations I meaning governments of
developed and developing countries of
all the international institutions that
are evolved the pharmaceutical companies
and everybody there's a lot of people
working on this major foundations like
the Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation
but if you stand back from it and look
it's kind of stalled it's not we do not
we have not found a way in terms of
global
government governance to get at this
problem agriculture the advanced
countries have politically motivated
protectionist oriented fights with each
other my image of international
negotiations about agricultural
subsidies and trade barriers is we first
argue with Japan and then we argue with
Europe and then the Europeans argue with
each other and we you know Dave Brady
and that whole group could explain to us
why this happens I understand and don't
mean to be naive about it but once again
that pattern of interference in open
markets because its main effect in the
developing countries we're probably 70%
of the people are in agriculture and
these are barriers to supply side
adjustments the market conditions that
have I think by general agreement a
large negative affects the global
markets by the standard of the markets
that Myron was describing a few minutes
ago
are relatively immature economically and
mean information Lee that is if you take
the standard as as the information
network and flow and insight and
research that surrounds the best of our
domestic financial markets and thence
ask what fraction of that if we achieved
in the global markets because we're on a
learning curve as we haven't learn about
more assets and so on the answer is
we're making big progress but but they
are information lien mature they are
volatile as a result and that volatility
has caused considerable harm to people
and so one of the the thing I want to
say about this is is a more general
point but this illustrates it there's no
theory that I know of that suggests that
markets that have informational
asymmetries that are serious of the type
we studied 30 years ago or markets that
are informational ii immature will work
just fine in the absence of regulation i
I just nobody who's smart has stood up
and said that markets work beautifully
when the informational system
surrounding them is quite
perfect even if there's residual risk
and the institutions are built up to
handle that but the point I'm trying to
make is that the market system in the in
the global economy is being oversold and
that's part of the the pushback that's
coming from the anti-globalization
movement it's being oversold not because
it is it's unimportant
anybody who's a serious student of the
experiments that were conducted in how
to run an economy in the 20th century
will realize that the market system one
and various forms of planned economies
didn't
so nobody now would stand up and say you
don't need a market system now
translated it into scientific language
that means the market system is a
necessary condition if you're any
economy but particularly one that's
relatively poor in short and resources
you can't operate inefficiently and
expect to grow and thrive over time so
we all agree on that then it's a very
short step to the statement all you need
is a market system that translated into
science is a market system is necessary
and sufficient and you don't have to
worry about public sector investment in
infrastructure in human capital you
don't have to worry terribly about the
building of the regulatory system that
allows the market and legal system you
don't have to worry a huge amount about
getting the current corruption of the
system and so on so it's it's a
fundamentally it's a model that people
carry around in their head hoping that
it's true and it's not I was asked by
European journalists today after we
talked about growth economic growth in
North America and Europe and Asia and
the rigidities in the European market
that make their labor markets and other
markets more you know difficult to
adjust this person asked me two
questions one was do you think the
Europeans should change and get rid of
these rigidities so they can grow faster
and adapt in a world that's requiring
fairly fair up adaptation I said no it's
not the job of an American
if you can if you get rid of rigidities
that are just totally unnecessary
then the answer surely yes their pension
systems are poorly constructed for
example they've got people with divine
benefits retiring at 57 with it life
expectancies of you know 80 plus years I
mean it's financially impossible and
they can't just can't stick with that
they'll have to go to a menu of options
that look something like a defined
contribution system so people have to do
a calculation of how much income they
want per year as they get older but but
my real response is it's not for an
American to tell Europeans how to make
the choice between safety nets and
protecting people and economic
efficiency and growth to the extent
that's the issue that's that's I can
easily see why people would make a
different choice than we have in America
and then this person said are you
optimistic or pessimistic about the
global economy and I did a typical
academic thing I paused and then I said
I'm cautiously optimistic then I thought
that's pretty embarrassing I better
explain what that means
it just just sounds like hedging of the
worst kind rather than the good kind
what I mean is I'm optimistic because I
think we have the means to deal with the
problems that I've waved my hands at
that you understand might describe
differently and I'm cautious because I'm
not sure if we have the will it's just
that simple
so my uncertainty about the future is
not whether we have a way to deal with
these problems however challenging they
are but whether we'll get organized to
actually do something about let me just
conclude by saying a few words because I
wanted to leave some time for your
questions rather than just go on about
stages in life I actually think
Shakespeare is right there are stages in
life they are accompanied by gradual
transitions
but the reason I say that is that I'd
like to try to characterize the stage
you're in and I think of it as the
period in your life in which your
creative power is at its maximum it's
it's clearly associated right in my mind
with youth that doesn't mean there are
very creative people who are older but
there are reasons why this is the period
in which you have the greatest capacity
to create something new and to change
the way people see or experience the
world or even each other first of all
you've got the energy second you've got
mental and emotional discipline that
you've developed in your careers to date
including these demanding educational
institutions and hopefully the
educational institutions have helped
build that set of capabilities you've
wrestled with intellectual and emotional
complexity by now in your life and
that's important but the most important
thing is that in some deep sense you're
unbiased
you are not jaded or trapped by either
your own experience or the accumulated
conclusions and conventional wisdom that
you find in all fields of endeavor
there's nothing wrong by the way with
conventional wisdom because it is sort
of wisdom the problem is its
conventional and because it's
conventional it's the enemy of
creativity
it's a substitute for wondering if you
can see this in a totally different way
so I think you have now at the height of
your powers the capacity to look at
familiar things and to see them in a
totally different way and understand
that they could actually be different
and this ability will last for an
unknown number of years maybe 20 and
none of this is specific to the choices
that you make about work or career there
are lots of examples of creativity that
you know about in the fields you'll be
in on stages and libraries labs garages
legislatures Wall Street all over the
place in at this point I wanted to make
and it doesn't have anything to do with
being well-known or famous in fact the
truth is that doesn't matter
much at all and there's nothing urgent
about it the way I think about it you
don't have to rush around and try to
find something that you really want to
do that's creatively different it'll
just going to happen later in life in
addition to all the achievements you'll
piled up you'll be good at lots of
things as well you'll have a lot of
experience you'll be wiser you probably
won't feel wiser
you'll be grandparents you'll have led
organizations lots of things and all of
that will be thrust upon you in a
perfectly natural way and it'll occupy
as it should time and energy and
emotional commitment but it will also
slowly take away from you the intensity
of focus that you tend to have now that
you can't have later on with all these
other demands on your time and energy
when I was a PhD student in economics
the conventional wisdom was and I
believe still is that you should finish
your coursework
take the general exams pick a safe topic
for your thesis one that fits into a
well-defined niche in a discipline get
it done graduate get a job learn to
teach and then finally you can think
about becoming creative and doing
something original in your field so I
thought that didn't sound like much fun
so I ignored it and I set out into
largely uncharted territory in economics
the details at which don't matter for
this purpose and my advisers very
powerful and wonderful human beings ken
arrow Tom shaoling and dick Zach Hauser
I could have said to me Mike you know we
really think this is awfully risky and
if they had to be honest with you they
had the kind of stature or an influence
on me if they had done that I'm not sure
to this day whether I would have tread
out on a path or a road that was
somewhat less traveled by but they
didn't say that instead they said just
go give it a try and so I guess what I'm
trying to do by telling you this story
today
in a very small way is to do for you
what they did for me and that is this
when you stumble and I use that word
advisedly on an idea a vision an
opportunity whatever it is that may
change the way people see or understand
or act or organize themselves and deal
with the challenges and opportunities
that we face and I believe you will and
this is the only vice I'll hand out
today my advice would be just go for it
thanks very much
a bit more detailed what you mean by
information asymmetries in developing
markets I mean what's what's the major
major problem and what needs to be done
I don't think what I was referring to
there is some markets have let me be a
little bit theoretical here economically
many markets have naturally symmetries
that adversely affect their performance
many of those markets can't self correct
the the the adverse selection and other
things that are caused by a symmetries
is too great in the developed a
countries for example many financial
markets have this characteristic as a
problem of unregulated financial
disclosure now it's true institutions
would develop around that and do in
other countries companies are privately
held trust matters families matter I
mean I don't want to be overly simple
about this there are ways around this
but if you look carefully at China what
you see is an increasingly pattern of
relying on markets including their
nascent financial markets and and a
careful building up in parallel of the
regulatory and other institutions that
are the supporting kind of public sector
side of it all of that takes time the
other thing that takes time is for teams
if you like or cohorts of investors who
are used to focusing on specific
domestic classes of assets for those
groups to become more broad in what they
look at I mean let me just write it so
if if we had a situation now in which
investors in Europe and America knew as
much about the financial structure and
risk structure of Korean corporations as
they do about American corporations then
some of the volatility we observed in
1998 wouldn't have occurred and that is
a combination of just human capital and
investment in making these markets work
with the informational underpinnings and
and it's partly regulation and
disclosure
there's a one other problem in that in
the global economy which I didn't talk
about but let me just mention it quickly
I believe that sometimes market markets
move around so fast they hurt people
more than is tolerable and in most
countries what happens when that happens
is the government steps in and gets in a
way of the market forces and does
something about it my description of
that is politics
Trump's economics you know when it
matters and actually I think that's the
way the world should be in the global
economy you do not have yet a the analog
of the domestic governance structure of
the economy at least in a democratic
country you've got institutions that are
learning but they're incomplete and and
indeed one of the more intelligent parts
of the anti-globalization movement is
concern about the governance structure
of the global economy the ability
decisively and with appropriate
authority to step in when it's needed in
exactly the way that our Federal Reserve
Bank steps in when there's a liquidity
problem or something else in our own
economy these are things we now take for
granted but learn painfully through the
our inability to do it in the great
crash and the Great Depression and so on
that's the kind of thing I mean it's a
it's a it's a complex set of things but
they are not built yet in the global
economy you talked about being
cautiously optimistic where we have the
means but perhaps not the will can you
talk a little bit more about why this
demographic in particular maybe lacks
that well in order to effect change on a
global scale when presumably we're the
right kind of people to affect that
change I don't think your demographic
either by age or in any other way
actually is deficient in this what what
I do think in fact I think it may be the
reverse let me put it in slightly more
concretely the the older demographic in
Europe could care less about Europe many
of those people don't plan
leave their town and they got quite
quite used to Lera thank you and they
didn't appreciate the price increases
that occurred when they converted to the
euro the young people really believed in
Europe they believed in labour mobility
multilingual stuff and so on at least as
best I can tell so there'll be a natural
changing of the political will as the
younger generation you know becomes a
more dominant force just by getting
older
but the thing we have in common is that
we learn from a very early age about our
own system and about politics and about
thinking about our communities and think
of all the things you learn you know
when you're Christ or if you're growing
up and in this school in particular and
I think what what I really believe is
that unless we learn to add this one
other piece which is recognizing that we
collectively have an enormous amount of
influence in this area and we need to
sort of think about it first and then
act on it second I mean what I would
hope is that twenty years from now when
you're the dominant you and your
colleagues are the dominant sort of
leaders of the major institutions in the
country that we would also have in all
of the advanced countries governments
that have because the citizens require
it clearly defined intentions and goals
with respect to the rest of the world
that are embedded in a structure where
they can actually happen and and I think
if we don't do that then we'll live in a
world that nobody put differently if we
the reason for doing that is purely in
the end self-interested because the
alternative is to live in a world in
which there's increasing disaffection
and chaos that's really what I was
trying to get out there yes ma'am
I mentioned a lot about the choices you
made at the various stages and just
curious if you could do it again if
there's anything you do differently or
very least if there's something that you
wish you'd known then that you know now
yes there's one thing I didn't do and I
I now regret it I used to think that it
would be fun at some stage to you know
go into politics and I then I recovered
from that bit of insanity and and now I
think that was one of the dumbest ideas
I ever had but but what got lost in the
shuffle is I think there is a great deal
to be said in many of our countries and
it works pretty well here in America for
being involved in public policy in some
way and I think when I become being an
economist to an academic administrator I
learned a lot about organizations and
how they work and how to help people get
things done and I don't regret any of
that but if I have one regret I think I
would have liked I don't know how I
would have done it to spend some time
working on policy things you know either
in Washington or somewhere maybe in an
international organization but where
that was the focus as opposed to getting
the organization to define and deliver
on its mission but that's really the
only exception I can think of yes one
more yes
you mentioned also that your your
energies are kind of diffused right now
in a lot of different directions
what was that Myron Pilates yeah
diet I'm actually that's a good question
I'm going back to economics and I'm not
sure you know when you've done it when
you're young and you're an applied
theorist what you know there's some
questions about what you're actually
going to do but the thing that
fascinates me most as somebody who
worked on the informational structure of
markets is trying to understand in the
long term what the effect of network
based information technology is on the
structure of markets the creation of
them the pricing in them the valuations
and so on that clearly if we can get to
think about that with somewhat greater
precision than we can now with the
benefit of models then I think there are
policy implications of that so I would
have to say I was interested in that but
then let me just give you two examples I
mean Bob Seoul will receive the Nobel
Prize for just extraordinarily important
work on technological change and it
continues to be an important part of
economics and the theory of economic
growth technical change is modeled as
operating on production functions
because in the context of economics at
the time that's perfectly natural and
that's not a crazy idea I could be
labor-saving or capital saving or just
operate overall well I believe with this
technology that we have technical change
that operates on production functions to
the extent that embedded in either
companies or firms or larger units are
what amount to transaction cost
reductions that are just hidden in there
in the function but we also are
experiencing change directly on
transaction costs visibly on transaction
cost and so we haven't modeled that yet
right
women model change in
train patterns and absolute relative
prices that result from not from
changing the production functions but
changing the accessibility of the inputs
or and the production from and
Protestant arts the second observation
is and this may be a little bit bogus
but if you look at the outsourcing of
various kinds of information technology
related services to India and other
countries this may be the first time in
which human capital or an input is
directly an input to a production
function of a service that's being
delivered in another country that's not
the conventional supply chain the
conventional supply chain which is
usually when people are imaging they're
thinking about manufacturing there's a
production function over there there's
an economy with a vector of assets that
determines productivity and relative
prices they have a cost advantage and
then there are a bunch of other costs
you have to incur including some
confusion and whatnot
in order to take advantage of that asset
and then get the goods to the market
where it needs to be this is a much more
direct effect I mean you have you have
Indian labor delivering services minute
by minute to customers and consumers in
all of our countries so that's the kind
of thing that I think at least Bears
looking at in and from an economic point
of view and I'm not a try to follow the
technology but and there are things
related to what Erik's going to talk
about that are similar to that family
that's a bit long-winded that's where
I'd like to be thanks very much
you